avec vos lenstra bonjour allen grosjean
pioline à la une de la presse comme à la
une du journal de damien coq et
l'intensification des tractations
diplomatiques pour tenter de désamorcer
le conflit en ukraine la tournée de la
dernière chance la visite du chancelier
allemand en ukraine aujourd'hui et en
russie deux mains est en tout cas
présenté par le hamburger morgenpost
comme la mission la plus difficile de la
scholtes un compromis est-il encore
possible le chancellier peut-il empêcher
la guerre le tabloïd de hambourg évoque
une épreuve du feu pour le chef du
gouvernement allemand dont ce sera la
première visite avec vladimir à vladimir
poutine une épreuve compliquée par les
positions pro russe de l'ancien
chancelier allemand gerhard schröder
d'après l'opinion qu'il définit comme un
caillou dans la chaussure de la scheulte
dont il fut d'ailleurs le mentor avant
de se reconvertir en super lobbyistes du
secteur énergétique russe garde
fraudeurs est en effet le président du
conseil d'administration de rosneft
le premier groupe pétrolier russe et
celui du comité d'actionnaires de nord
stream 2 le gazoduc russo allemand
controversé également invité dans ce
ballet diplomatique gerbe also narrow
est lui aussi attendu demain à moscou
selon l'humanité le président brésilien
entendre est quant à lui sortir de son
statut de paria et jouer les mid les
médiateurs au grand dam des états unis
qui se serait bien passé de l'entrée en
scène de ce nouvel acteur réputé
imprévisible et côté américain et russe
à la fois
chacun campe sur ses positions farce
attaque titre commerçante à propos des
mises en garde américaine sur une
attaque imminente de l'ukraine par la
russie le quotidien russe évoque lui le
scénario envisagé par moscou d'une
provocation ukrainiennes ou d'une tierce
partie dans le donbass pour entraîner la
réussite dans la guerre je cite le
spectre d'un conflit en ukraine
largement évoqué ce matin par la presse
européenne photo de civils l'ukrainien
supposément prêts à en découdre à
l'appui comme ses habitants en cours
trouvent à la une du parisien
aujourd'hui en france s'entraînant
rudiments du combat militaire dans des
forêts à proximité de kiev au kazoo des
ukrainiens de 7 à 77 ans et même au delà
dont valentina konstantinos qui à 79 ans
à la une ce matin de plusieurs
quotidiens anglo-saxons dont le
quotidien britannique the times ou
encore ceux là voilà le ce jeune garçon
a qu'on retrouve à la une du indians ont
photographié à marioupol c'est dans
l'est de l'ukraine au bord de la mer
d'azov auquel on apprend à retirer les
balles d'un chargeur une gare d image à
laquelle participent aussi les
dessinateurs de presse en ce jour de
saint valentin la lumière poutine les
représenter à la fois comme un
personnage mafieux et comme influence
est dépité d'être éconduits souama
valentine a mitraillé le président russe
sur les portes de l'ukraine dans le
destin de morlanne pour the times
vladimir poutine métamorphosé en cupidon
dans le dessein de nicolas jennings pour
the guardian
soit me pardonnez moi prêt a tiré son
missile sur l'ukraine from russia with
love de la part de la russie avec amour
la crise russo ukrainienne hélène qui
partagent la une de la presse française
avec le début du procès aujourd'hui des
complices présumés des assassins du père
jacques hamel le temps de la justice
annonce la croix le journal chrétien qui
s'est rendu dans la petite ville de
saint-etienne du rouvray là où le père
hamel a été assassiné en juillet 2016
dans son église par de djihadistes de 19
ans réclamant du groupe etat islamique
voit dans ce procès l'occasion de
renvoyer une autre image de la france
que celle que renvoie les partisans je
cite des discours de haine et on y
reviendra dans les journaux la presse
française qui revient enfin hélène sur
l'incroyable performance de canton
fillon mallet aux jo de pékin n'a même
neuf ans le skieur français a écrit hier
un nouveau chapitre de sa fabuleuse
épopée chinoise en décrochant la
médaille d'or sur la poursuite son
deuxième titre après l'individuel et sa
quatrième médaille en argent sur le
sprint et le relais mixte l'équipe en
est toute ébouriffée le vent de
l'histoire titre amoureusement
quotidien sportif et puisque l'on parle
d'amour quelle transition en ce jour de
saint-valentin bonne fête à tous les
amoureux et notamment aux miens et tout
particulièrement à paul 81 18 ans et
louisette 88 ans regardez ci sont pas
beaux ils sont la preuve vivante que
l'amour n'a pas d'âge pauline et oui
leur belle histoire nous a raconté par
nos confrères de france bleu les
tourtereaux part et ils sont tombés
amoureux il ya un peu plus de deux ans
après s'être rencontrés via une agence
matrimoniale
ils se sont depuis mis en ménage dans
une résidence d'autonomie où il coule
des jours parfaitement heureux on
s'embrasse 20 à 25 fois par jour on ne
fait que ça révèle vous êtes merveilleux
merveilleux et quelle photo merci
beaucoup et l'aisne